a phobia is an excessive fear of a
seemingly harmless thing and those
affected go to great lengths to avoid
certain situations
if a situation cannot be avoided they
experience severe distress panic attacks
or even fainting
phobias are less prevalent among
children and older people and more
common among teenagers and especially
girls
they run in families or can be the
result of a traumatic experience early
in life
phobias can be categorized into three
types
a social phobia is when we fear others
especially their judgment
agoraphobia is the fear of a situation
we perceive to be unsafe or difficult to
escape
specific phobias include fears of
certain things or situations such as
heights or injuries and seeing blood
some phobias are especially complicated
such as the famous case of the button
boy
it was a normal day at kindergarten when
a six-year-old boy ran out of buttons to
paste on his poster board and was asked
to come to the front of the class to get
some more
when he reached for the bowl his hand
slipped and all the buttons fell on him
for the boy this was a deeply traumatic
event
[Music]
not long after he didn't want to dress
himself anymore
he began to have difficulty
concentrating in class due to an
excessive preoccupation with not
touching his school uniform
and eventually he started avoiding
people just to stay away from their
buttons
life became so difficult that four years
after the incident the boy and his
mother decided to seek professional help
the psychiatrists lacet salvedra and
wendy silverman who studied the case
were able to rule out
obsessive-compulsive disorder ocd which
is often confused with a phobia and
concluded that the boy must have
developed a specific phobia for
buttons to treat the boy the doctors
invited the mother and son to be part of
a research project
to assess the child's progress
throughout the treatment they used a
feelings thermometer allowing the boy to
grade each interaction from one feeling
happy to nine feeling angry
big brass jeans buttons hardly bothered
the boy but small clear plastic ones
horrified him
after the boy's feelings were better
understood the doctors selected a
treatment method
first they tried behavioral exposure
therapy a form of classical conditioning
whenever the boy touched a button
successfully he was rewarded
they then repeated the process in
various forms
after four sessions the boy completed
all tasks and he was able to interact
with way more buttons than before
however he felt more distressed about
buttons than ever
when the doctors talked to the boy again
he revealed that he found buttons
disgusting and that they omitted a bad
smell
and so they wondered did the exposure
therapy reduce his fear but increase his
feeling of disgust
[Music]
next they tried imagery exposure therapy
for the seven sessions that followed the
boy was prompted to just visualize
buttons falling on him and imagine how
they looked felt and smelled
[Music]
this time the boy's self-reported levels
of distress reduced dramatically
even 12 months after the therapy the boy
reported minimal fear of buttons
so why did the first treatment fail
while the second one worked
the first treatment changed the mind's
expectations of what harmless buttons
may trigger classical conditioning
the second therapy change the mind's
evaluation of buttons themselves that
they aren't actually that disgusting
in technical terms expectancy learning
failed but evaluative learning succeeded
but treatment of a phobia may take many
forms social and agoraphobia are often
treated with counselling or even
medication
specific phobias are often treated by
systematic desensitization
today often with the help of virtual
reality
humor is another serious therapy that
often works activities that elicit humor
with the feared situation can help
reduce disgust anxiety or whatever other
uncovered feelings may be the cause of
our phobia
what's your experience with phobia have
you ever had one that you were able to
overcome and if so how did you do it
share your thoughts in the comments
below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons
that means teachers from all around the
world can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's
slash
patreon.com